regardez sur tana dessous dans la grosse
rigolade c'est énormément de début de
blague mais pas de fin et c'est pour ça
qu'on les aime c'est devenu une légende
de cette émission regardée chantal
ladesou dans la grosse rigolade à
regarder est-ce que tu as une blague
toit de chevaux chameaux way est un
éléphant pour la première fois dans ce
recoin cependant pour la première fois
je veux leur faire
chameaux et un éléphant se rencontrent
pour la première fois alors il faut
aider pourquoi tu as de nichons sur le
dos aux chameaux et le camp des enjeux
et les freins le chameau didier toi
pourquoi tel mythe sur la tête les
imiter et aux dons c'est bon on est dans
ta jolie c'est que c'est tout
c'est le mec qui dit hiver et celle de
moments chapelle où j'arrive pas son
temps que des trucs
elles marchent pas bien je devrais dire
d'alger laquelle a marché qu'est ce que
tu as demandé 50 euros mais pas compris
j'ai compris pourquoi tes blagues ne
marchait pas je te jure
en fait c'est sur l'intonation de faim
de blague on croit qu'elle n'est pas
finie et chantal ladesou est avec nous
est ce qu'on peut montrer ce qu'on voit
de chantal à tous parce que même là elle
galère depuis tout à l'heure on voit
tout le talent sauf total normal chantal
ça va devoir est ce que tu me vois oui
mais je te vois je te vois à l'envers
ouais bah voilà change d'appartement
mèneront à l'horizontale